hey guys comes to go into seam here I'm
really excited about the side she likes
episode because I've actually got stuff
to talk about it seems like it's first
time while I can talk a lot about
absolutely nothing the best of all weeks
I don't even know if I've done a Jay
likes episode but one video that keeps
popping up non-stop and people can't
stop that is Miley Cyrus is lucid even
well he thought I won't stop doesn't
really matter what it's called because
it honestly makes me extremely
uncomfortable ah not a lot of things
really make me uncomfortable with this
music video it was like what are you
doing Oh what are you you're thrusting
you're humping you're cutting your I
don't even know I don't know I'm not
sure I I have no words the words that I
have they're non-existent so Miley I
guess keep doing what you're doing
because people who are talking about it
and I do actually like her hair though I
do like it who is next video kind of
took me into the YouTube wormhole of no
return you notice when you watch one
video and then you start watching
another another another another and
you're like where does the past hour ago
well you guys may be familiar with
Charlotte the unicorn from many years
ago I guess they've rebooted the series
named Charlie the Unicorn
not to be confused with th e it's teh
illu this I was playing Mario's at the
time not good Mario falls down a lot but
after I watched this video I got sucked
in was watching years of animation
videos by this dude and I was just
losing my mind
so good so so good do the next video I'm
a little biased because I make a cameo
this past week of internet icon I was a
guest judge so be sure to go check it
out watched in the past episodes there's
so many talented youtubers on this show
and sadly not all of them can make the
cut to the next episode which sucks
because everybody is creative I love
everyone and having to vote somebody off
of a show is the most difficult thing
that I've ever had to do
that's a lie I climbed the glacier I
think that was probably the most
difficult thing I've ever done and I
would do it again now in gaming and tech
news I am super excited because the new
map pack for call of duty black ops 2
was released it's vengeance with few new
multiplayer maps in a zombie mode and
the other parts of this technology
segment oh boy I've been obsessed with
this camera is the Samsung Galaxy at
camera no this isn't sponsored but I saw
this at CES this past year and I've been
thinking about it since then it's
essentially the Samsung Galaxy fold but
in a camera for it's running full on
freaking Android you basically can't
download apps you can take photos and
post them directly to Instagram you take
videos posted to the youtubes I mean
look at this screen it's so huge
yeah what what this is the future
everybody ladies and gentlemen let me
introduce you to the future waiting
siblings pop out well that was pretty
anti-climatic last we've got our beauty
and style segment brush the shoulder off
once again I've been using this
waterproof eyeliner in Sephora I've
never worn waterproof eyeliner in my
entire life so I'm sure there may be a
better brand out there
for the sake of it being my first time
this is the first one that I've ever
used it's pretty awesome it doesn't come
off at all my latest and greatest and
most favoritest color for summer is this
color you can see I am first at this
color
well teks saw my obsession and I guess
they just got my size in and I had a
little surprise maybe in my door today
shoes to match my purse so it's longer
highlighter yellow one
but she's more like Corinne oh wow now
for the feet
people here I'll show you with you
because you guys like that that's really
all I've got for you uh in this video
you guys haven't seen my Google glass
music video I had too much fun shooting
this looking at you through the glass
watch me running in the grass I have
always been the biggest fan of Stone
Sour I used to be a slipknot fan so
people don't actually believe me but
trust me I was Jess my mom she was not
happy about it but I've loved the song
through glass so when I use on this
hashtag start popping up and people were
using Google glass all I could hear was
the song playing through my head
so Brett Morgan helps me make the song
sound right fantastic
go check it out I love you guys and I
will see you in the next video going to
London so I'll see you there more
friends that was a terrible apologize
anyone who I may have offended I'm gonna
shut up now I'll see you later bye